build a free open claw in eight minutes.
So, I found something wild. You can now
build your own AI agent. It runs all day
and all night. It does tasks for you
while you sleep and you do not need any
fancy gear. No Mac Mini, no special
computer, just the one you already have.
And it is completely free. No tricks, no
catch. I am going to show you exactly
how to do this in about 8 minutes. And
trust me, once you see this, you're
going to wonder why nobody told you
sooner. Let's go. Okay, so what even is
an AI agent? Let me break it down real
simple. Imagine you had a little helper
that lived inside your computer. You
tell it what to do and it just does it
on repeat without complaining, without
taking breaks. That is what this is. You
give it a job, it runs that job and it
keeps running it until you tell it to
stop. You wake up in the morning and
stuff is already done. That is the power
of this. Now, before I go any further,
let me be real with you. There are
people out there making this way harder
than it needs to be. They want you to
think you need some crazy setup, special
hardware. That is not true. What I am
about to show you works on a basic
laptop and every single tool we use
today is free. Everyone, hey, if we
haven't met already, I'm the digital
avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates.
Julian Goldie reads every comment, so
make sure you comment below. Right? So,
let me tell you why this matters.
Because I know some of you are thinking,
"Okay, cool. another AI thing, but this
is different. This is not just some
chatbot that answers your questions.
This thing actually goes and does stuff.
It can write for you. It can research
for you. It can check things for you. It
can build things for you. And it does
all of this on its own. You set it up
once. You give it instructions and then
you walk away. That is the game changer
here. So, let me walk you through how
this works. The whole system runs inside
something called a container. Think of
it like a bubble. Your agent lives
inside that bubble on your computer. It
cannot touch anything else. It cannot
break anything. It just sits in its
little bubble and does its work safe,
clean, simple. And the reason this
matters is because you do not want some
random AI messing with your files or
your system. This keeps everything
separate. Now, inside that bubble, there
are a few parts working together. There
is a brain part that is the thing that
thinks. It figures out what to do and
when to do it. Then there is a worker
part. That is the thing that actually
goes and does the job. And then there is
a guard part that keeps everything
locked down and secure. These three
things work together and you can see all
of them running on your screen. Nothing
is hidden. You know exactly what your
agent is doing at all times. Here is the
part that I think is genius. Every
single thing your agent does gets saved.
Every task it runs, every change it
makes, every decision, it is all
recorded. So you can go back tomorrow
and look at what it did today. You can
go back next week and see everything
from this week. is like having a full
diary of everything your AI agent has
ever done. And if you want to get really
smart about it, you can tell your agent
to look at its own history and figure
out how to do things better. It
literally teaches itself. That is not
science fiction. That is real and it is
running right now. Now, the setup, this
is the part everyone worries about, but
honestly, it is so simple that I almost
feel silly walking you through it. You
open your terminal. That is just a text
window on your computer. You paste in
one line. The system asks you a few
questions. You answer them and then it
builds everything for you. The whole
thing takes minutes, not hours, not
days, minutes. And once it is built, it
is built. You do not have to do it
again. Now, if you are serious about
using AI to actually grow and get more
done, you need to check out the AI
profit boardroom. This is the best
community to learn how to set up AI
agents like this and plug them straight
into your business. Whether you run an
agency, a side project, or you are just
getting started, the boardroom shows you
step by step how to automate with AI
tools like OpenClaw.
The link is in the description and the
comments. Go check it out right now
while it is fresh in your mind. Okay, so
back to the good stuff. Once your agent
is set up, you get this beautiful chat
screen. It looks just like the big AI
tools. You type a message, your agent
reads it, thinks about it, and then it
goes and does the thing. And you can
watch it happen in real time. The text
streams across the screen just like when
you talk to any major AI. But the
difference is this one is yours. It
lives on your machine. Nobody else can
see what you're doing with it. And get
this, you can upload files to it, PDFs,
images, whatever you have, drop it in.
Your agent grabs it and works with it.
Need it to pull information from a
document? Done. Need it to look at an
image and tell you something about it?
Done. It handles all of that right
inside the chat. Now, let me talk about
the scheduling piece because this is
where things get really powerful. You
can set up a schedule for your agent.
Tell it to wake up every 10 minutes,
every hour, every day at a certain time,
whatever you want, and every time it
wakes up, it runs the task you gave it.
So, imagine this. You tell your agent to
check for new leads every 30 minutes or
to scan the web for something specific
every hour or to create a summary of
your day every night. It just does it
over and over without you having to
remember, without you having to do
anything.
And here is something most people do not
know about. You can set up rules so that
your agent checks with you before it
makes any changes. So if it writes
something or creates something, it shows
you first. You look at it. If you like
it, you approve it. If you do not, you
tell it to try again. Full control. But
if you trust your agent and you want it
to just go, you can flip a switch and
let it run without asking. Totally up to
you. The other thing I love is how easy
it is to update. There is a button. You
press it, the system updates itself.
That is it. No downloading new files, no
starting over. One button and your agent
keeps running the whole time. It
upgrades itself while it is still
working. That blew my mind the first
time I saw it. Now, I want to talk about
something big. This system is built to
grow. Right now, you can run one agent
on one computer. But the way this is
designed, you can add more. You can have
five agents, 10 agents, 50 agents, all
running at the same time, all doing
different things, all managed from one
screen. So, if you start small, that is
totally fine. But know that you can
scale this up whenever you are ready.
The system is ready for it. And the
community around this is growing fast.
People are building agents for all kinds
of things, research, writing,
monitoring, analysis, and they are
sharing what they build. So you can
learn from what other people are doing.
You can take their setups and tweak them
for your own needs. It is like having a
library of pre-built agents that you can
just plug in and use. Let me also
mention the phone thing because this is
cool. You can connect your agent to a
messaging app on your phone. So, you do
not even need to be at your computer.
You can send your agent a message from
your phone. Tell it to do something and
it does it from anywhere on the bus, in
a meeting, at the gym. Your agent is
always ready. And the security on this
is tight. Everything is encrypted. Your
data stays on your machine. Nothing goes
to some random server. If you are
running it from home, there are free
tools that create a secure tunnel so
everything is protected. If you move it
to the cloud later, it handles security
automatically. Either way, your stuff is
safe. Now, here is what gets me fired
up. Think about where we are. A year
ago, none of this was possible. And now
you can have a full AI agent running on
your own computer doing real work for
free. This is the kind of shift that
changes everything. And most people are
going to miss it because they think it
is too hard. But you just saw how easy
it is. 8 minutes. That is all it takes.
So, if you want to take this further, if
you want to learn how to plug AI agents
like OpenClaw straight into your
business to save time and automate the
stuff that slows you down, the AI profit
boardroom is exactly where you need to
be. We show you how to use these tools
to get more leads, serve more clients,
and automate the boring stuff. The link
is in the description and the comments.
And if you want the full process, SOPs,
and over a 100 AI use cases like this
one, join the AI success lab links in
the comments and description. You'll get
all the video notes from there, plus
access to our community of 38,000
members who are crushing it with AI.
Julian Goldie reads every comment, so
drop your questions below. I will see
you in the next